[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo a directo kobe 26
el programa especial de france 24 para
debatir lo que ocurre en la cumbre
climática de la onu en glasgow allí está
nuestra enviado especial de marina
colorado con todas las actualizaciones
de los debates que están en proceso hoy
las discusiones están precisamente
enfocadas en temas de género de ciencia
y también de innovación sobre ese primer
tema hay un llamado por una mayor
inclusión de las mujeres en las
representaciones climáticas y es que es
esa población la que se ve
principalmente afectada y de manera
desproporcional por los impactos del
cambio climático
la activista de samoa briana afro wine
llamó a los delegados en la cumbre a
plantar semillas de un futuro mejor para
las mujeres y las niñas vamos a ahondar
sobre este tema y para eso nos dirigimos
hasta glasgow con nuestra enviada
especial la marina colorado marina la
escuchamos
pues sí como decías vamos a ahondar en
este tema de género y nos acompaña gina
cortes valderrama y ya eres
representante del grupo constituyente de
mujeres y género gracias por estar en
france 24 te pregunto qué hace este
grupo que tú representas
gracias el grupo constituyente de
mujeres y género es uno de los nuevos
grupos que representan la sociedad civil
dentro de la convención marco por el
cambio climático y nosotros no sólo nos
aseguramos que las voces de las mujeres
de base de aquellas que están en la
primera línea enfrentando las
consecuencias del cambio climático sean
visibilizadas y exploradas en este
espacio sino también para garantizar que
estas voces sus necesidades sus
prioridades y su conocimiento sea
integrado dentro de la política nacional
e internacional para darle frente al
cambio climático es así como también nos
aseguramos a partir de negociaciones y
reuniones bilaterales que los gobiernos
entiendan claramente el nexo entre
género cambio climático y por qué es
importante para incrementarla y así
lograr las metas del acuerdo de parís y
precisamente acerca de esta inequidad
cuál es la situación de la inequidad de
género en la crisis climática a nivel
global y en particular en américa
latina'
bueno particularmente no solamente en
américa latina pero también en todo el
mundo estamos todavía bajo modelos
económicos que son extractivistas que
son patriarcales bajo un modelo de
extraer todos los recursos sin tener en
cuenta los derechos humanos sin tener en
cuenta
la temporalidad de nuestros recursos y
así afectando y desplazando a muchas
comunidades esto ha dejado bastante
secuelas no solo en el medio ambiente
pero también en la identidad cultural en
la identidad de lo que somos como
sociedad es por eso que necesitamos
garantizar el derecho a un ambiente
seguro a un ambiente sano y a un
ambiente sostenida sostenible el cual ya
fue reconocido por la comisión para
derechos humanos de las naciones unidas
todo esto bajo un marco de género
teniendo en cuenta cuáles son las
soluciones que en verdad nos funcionan
aquí ya no queremos más soluciones
falsas no queremos más discursos de net
sirve sino de verdad acción verdadera y
esta acción ya está pasando en los
locales ya está pasando a nivel regional
a nivel local desde las comunidades de
base que con su conocimiento ancestral
con sus prácticas en agroecología con
sus prácticas en economía solidaria nos
están demostrando cuál es la verdadera
acción que necesitamos una acción basada
en los recursos naturales una acción
pasada en las comunidades y basada en
los derechos humanos pues muchísimas
gracias y en anacortes valderrama por tu
tiempo en directo con 26 de france 24 de
volvemos al estudio en bogotá aquí desde
glasgow marina gracias a usted ya
nuestros televidentes de recordarles que
todos los días hacemos cubrimiento y
actualizaciones de lo que pasa en la
cumbre del clima sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com
buenas tardes
[Música]